Hamilton is a surfing pioneer and also
an icon of the sport a new documentary
follows his journey to Raj some of the
world's biggest waves it is called take
every wave the life of Laird Hamilton in
an interview from our PBS show Hamilton
shared how he always wanted to be a
surfer at the core of it is something
you love and have lot since you were how
old
as as early as I can remember that just
I've never not not wanted to be a surfer
and and never I can't remember not just
not loving it not wanting to always love
it is to thrill the risk always that
thrilled something else the thrill
something else the thrill is is an act
in nature it's it's for me it's the
ultimate act in nature that you're now
the fact that it's thrilling and
dangerous is part of the people well
yeah that's part of the act of a real
situation in nature when you're under a
giant one a giant what's the focus of
your mind well the focus of your mind is
still you get still and you get a
certain calmness that is demanded of you
to survive it and so it forces you into
a certain state that feels I think feels
some somewhat primal and natural like it
feels like I need I need to be in that
situation or I've been there many times
before and and it's something that makes
me feel complete like I I feel like I'm
actually accomplishing something here on
on the planet that I'm supposed to be
doing you were supposed to be surfing I
am he's amazing and not only is he the
gifted surfer but he's been responsible
for a lot of innovations in terms of
using jet skis to take these surfers way
to hell out in the ocean and capture the
ways way or like yeah the best wave the
highest waves and so he's really been a
pilot long till Laird gives you some
surface December
oh it's planned yes there's a date on
the calendar it's really great news
breaking news in Hawaii my wife okay all
right Charlie right all right you can
hear more from Blair to Hamilton and
Rory Kennedy the producer and director
of this documentary on CBS this morning
podcast learn how Hamilton's rebellious
nature allowed him to become a pioneer
in surfing you can find the podcast on
iTunes and Apple podcast app